show for those of you who join us every
monday during football season
we hand out superlatives so christopher
i will let you do the honors you get to
go first with your initial superlative
for week eight i mean i think the first
one i'm gonna go with is just the the
one game we haven't really
talked about yet
i mean the one-man superstar the one-man
band
the i mean the cookie the cookie monster
eating cookies i mean dalvin cook
i don't know what the hell i want to say
about it other than that like one
obviously superstar show okay that's
what it was well i wanted to make fun of
the packers too i wasn't sure where i
wanted to go with that but that game
itself was unbelievable yesterday and
dalvin cook of course was the star of
the show i mean green bay couldn't stop
him i mean in any capacity run game pass
game it didn't matter
you know and defense on green bay holy
cow i mean there's issues there i mean
this is why we you know i know we've
talked about how how real are the
packers i don't know i think it's just a
good team with a really great
quarterback that makes us think they're
super bowl caliber i don't really think
they're a super bowl caliber team you
know but dalvin cook the way he ran the
ball and controlled the clock for the
vikings yesterday and everything about
it that way was unbelievable i mean
think about this game you know first off
there was no defense in this game and
the packers were a team that we hold in
the i mean it was touchdown green bay
touchdown minnesota touchdown green bay
touchdown minnesota halftime minnesota
gets the ball touchdown green bay gets
the ball and it's only 21-14
but they've realized there's no way
we're gonna stop minnesota today every
play is gonna be four and five and six
and four and five and fifty
and they have to go for it on fourth and
ten on the 37-yard line because it's
21-14 now i know mason crosby was beat
up and it's a little weird part of the
field there but
that just speaks to you what they even
thought of their own defense on that day
they don't make the fourth and 10.
dalvin cook gets the screen pass or a
touchdown and it's like game over i mean
that that was it so that was an
unbelievable performance by him a guy
coming off injury nonetheless but i
think i'm also equally
as amazed as i was by him i'm equally as
amazedly concerned with green bay and
that performance it just shows once
again if they can't play with a lead and
make a team pass when teams can be
balanced everybody moves the ball on
green bay
it really was amazing it was like a
tennis match and the first break was
going to win it and and uh yeah that
that first half had four total
possessions crazy a touchdown a
touchdown a touchdown a touchdown back
and forth and then the vikings as you
said they start the second half of the
touchdown breaks serve they're up 28-14
and that's that and they had to they had
to hold on at the end yes they did it
felt for a while there like there was
going to be an aaron rodgers hail mary
straight up and straight down and he got
hit just as he was trying to let go of
the football who knows what would have
happened if that ball had come out
because we've seen it time and again
from aaron rodgers we may have been
talking about a 29-28 victory because
you know what they did when they were
down 28-14 chris and they scored the
touchdown they went analytics they did
too right i i don't know how you feel
about that that one's not as horrible so
i just that one's wow wow yeah i can
deal with that i can i mean it's not my
still not my favorite play
uh you know but but
i do understand the logic there to at
least like you go for two if you don't
make it you're still within one score
but you do set yourself up to win the
football game with that next score i can
get behind that one more than the we're
up by seven and let's go up by nine and
some of the other ones that are out
there that i don't like
but but it takes a one score game and
makes it a two score game yeah i like
that one yeah i don't like the ones
where
like either way it's still like
like wait a minute if you go for one or
you go for two it's still a one score
game if you get neither it's a two score
game why the hell are you doing that
right like i i don't understand those
but i understand this one and it almost
paid off but this is about dalvin cook
as you said alvin cook was phenomenal
163 rushing yards 63 receiving yards
four touchdowns the first vikings player
since
1979 coach dungey was on the field for
that game as a member of the 49ers
defense when ahmad rashad scored four
touchdowns for the vikings the only
other time it's happened for a viking
was chuck foreman on a snowy day in
buffalo in 1975 i remember watching that
game as a kid somebody hit foreman in
the eye with a snowball through his face
mask he was he was great that day he was
great that year what did he do and you
know when he got hit did he do anything
did he do anything i mean that could
that guy no he just you know he didn't
do anything i i think he kept playing
but yeah i mean it wasn't it wasn't
pleasant i mean i remember seeing like
the snow in his face mask and his aisle
covered up with it but it was it was
just one of those great old-school snow
games and it was a great saturday
afternoon game like the nfl used to do
early afternoon saturday games but uh i
digress i i would have sworn randy moss
had four touchdowns at one point but he
didn't
dalvin cook did and when i talked to him
after the game you know first of all he
said his groin's fine obviously the
groin's fine the injury is healed three
weeks later but you know i said when do
you know you're going to have a special
day like this he said well every game i
think is going to be like that we just
go out and we start playing and we see
how it goes and he said after that first
drive
he gets with kennedy palomalo the
running backs coach he got with rick
dennison the offensive line coach and
run game coordinator and he started
telling them what's going to work and
what's not going to work and they call
the plays that he thinks are going to
work and
you know that's good coaching when
you're receptive to what your players
are seeing out on the field where the
openings are where the weaknesses may be
and you're willing to change up the game
plan on the fly based on their input
it helps to have dalvin cook it does but
but when when you know some coaches are
stubborn about that they're going to do
it their way right chris they're not
going to listen
you you i coach and you play you let me
worry about the plays that are called
well i call your number you be ready to
go i like it when the players are
empowered and encouraged to give that
feedback because you know we talk all
the time well are you a field level or
you're sitting in the box there's no
perspective like being out there on the
field no right and if cook is seeing it
and he's able to communicate it in real
time and they're able to adjust in real
time look at look at what that vikings
offense can do yeah no i think it's uh
it's a great point and the fact of like
you know
you got to have that player that you can
you know
be in the trust tree with right there's
some running backs and receivers out
there they're just emotional and they
might come on the sideline and do this
but he's obviously you know
earned their trust that way to where
he's not an emotional rah-rah yell type
guy and he probably goes back and makes
some legit points and of course he's
very good successful talented football
player and good for them for listening
to them and he is he has some running
back man we got some big time running
backs in the nfl right now we really do
and look here look at kirk cousins
yesterday man you don't need to throw
the ball down the field right average
air yards
1.79 per attempt wow he completed 11 of
14 passes he averaged over 11 yards per
attempt in you know when you throw the
yardage in that that was gained after
the catch but for the air yards he was
just basically i mean i could throw
those yeah you could my right hand to
dalvin cook and let him run 50 right you
know that's that's that's again one of
the things i argue against a lot when
people started oh look at all this yards
per completion okay well if he's you
know if he's throwing the ball one yard
to the flat and the guy's running 20
yards i'm not really that impressed i
mean that's great and all but big win
for the vikings the vikings i heard
somebody on tv or i might have heard
like kyle rudolph over the weekend maybe
on pro football talk mike where you're
just talking about like
you know it is truly one of the better
two and five teams we've seen you know
we've been sarcastic of course you saw
it on pft is that when i saw it i
couldn't think of where the hell i saw
it i couldn't remember i wasn't being
sarcastic i couldn't remember but i will
say it is a very impressive two and five
team there's no doubt
you would have remembered if you didn't
have to wait 20 minutes to get in the
building today that wiped your memory
clean of everything i think some other
things like my memory clean this week
try to be nice
um all right first one for me maybe they
need obj after all award oh you know it
was funny last week that narrative where
the browns pushed back on the idea that
the offense uh may be better without
otto beckham jr no it won't be oh you're
right congratulations browns you're
right the offense isn't as good without
otto beckham jr now who knows if he
would have made a difference but man at
a time when we thought the browns were
maybe gonna start finding that gas pedal
win the games they should win and this
was the one that fell into that
i don't know maybe they win maybe they
lose you never know which raiders team
is going to show up well it was a cold
and windy and nasty day and the team
that isn't used to playing in cold windy
and nasty showed up and got it done
baker mayfield did not get it done now
the bulk of his passing numbers last
week came without odell beckham jr so
that's not an apples to apples thing in
any way shape or form but you're not
going to win many games when you're
starting quarterback has 122 passing
yards and your running game isn't there
either like it usually is and uh you
know it was it just felt like a lost
opportunity for the browns even though
it wasn't a blowout they never felt like
they were in sync they they just felt
like they were a half step behind the
raiders all day long and that that
proved itself yeah it definitely did i
think i think they're one of those teams
like we just mentioned a few minutes ago
too mike where it's like cleveland i
again they're a team i'll throw into the
category of if they can't run the ball
i'm not sure i trust the other elements
of their offense to really come through
i i think that's still a big question
mark got to give john gruden credit you
know the raiders football team yeah
there's you know they're trying to build
something there they're not perfect yet
but man they play tough they do play
tough and gruden has instilled some
toughness as far as their run game he
pounded the rock yesterday and they
physically just slowly wore down that
cleveland front that uh which was you
know it's one of the great strengths of
this raiders football team they have a
great offensive line you know so that
was it was a big win and you're right it
was just like
you thought oh cleveland's not playing
good but i don't know can they maybe
pull it out jarvis landry had a few
drops you know he has that play that you
know gets overturned in the end zone
hunter renfro has that other catch that
i also think hit the ground it just
wasn't a great angle to really prove it
they get the touchdown it was a close
football game but the raiders were the
desperate team and they came through and
uh
yeah we'll we'll see where it goes from
here
yeah i don't see much difference between
those two and one's a touchdown and
one's not a touchdown and there there
were some interesting replay review
calls yesterday and it becomes more
glaring because
officiating hadn't been an issue
most of the year the one but i i sent a
text around all the pft writers on
saturday where's the what's the
officiating controversy this year it's
the patrick mahomes in the grass play
remember that one yeah right against the
patriots against the patriots right
but if there were several yesterday and
we'll be talking about some of them
maybe coming up especially that weird
one last night in the cowboys eagles
game that yeah that allowed the eagles
to cover the spread when it looked like
vinnie curry was down with the ball but
somehow uh that wasn't overturned on
replay review all right chris what's
your next uh superlative um i got a
and the only cure is patrick mahomes
okay i got a fever florio all right i'm
going with a fever because he threw five
touchdown passes right fever five fever
that's not that's not a good that's not
a good i don't care that's what it came
he's not a good christopher walken no i
didn't even sound like phil simms
that says sorry that's just what i'm
going with here okay
my homie your homie my homie your homie
whenever he's on we watch because he's
amazing i don't even give a crap if it's
the jets all right i don't give a damn
mahomes you know quietly
21 touchdown passes one interception on
the year second in football in yards and
he's only second to matt ryan who's
losing every week so has to bring his
team back
right i mean
having an mvp caliber season i mean it's
he's the mvp of football if isn't for
one guy up in the northwest that's how
special it was and yesterday like it
wasn't their best football game but man
did he make some plays and throws that
again i just it's been an hour and we
haven't talked about the best team in
football and the best player in the game
and i just couldn't help it any longer
you know the the first touchdown pass i
believe it was down the middle to
machole hardman i mean without that was
the one i'm thinking about right or no
i'm thinking of the second one the 36
yard touchdown post down the middle mike
i mean you heard me when we were
watching yesterday i heard you oh i
heard you i heard you're here in west
virginia he doesn't know i heard what
you yelled out because some type of
missile yep uh it was a piss missile is
what i call it
we're digital aren't we it doesn't
matter anymore but either way
i mean he rared back and he doesn't
always rare back and let go for his 105
mile per hour fastball and he threw a
ball
48 yards down the field five feet off
the ground and i just went i mean i just
i was drooling but i just love watching
him play he's amazing and it's the
quietest 21-1 and i've ever seen out of
a quarterback where nobody talks about
it because
literally we are got to the point with
patrick mahomes where we expect him to
throw for 40 plus to 50 touchdown passes
and play awesome every week to where 4
16 and 5 touchdowns is really like
second hour news now in in mahome's life
that's how awesome he is
yeah and you made the observation too
when they showed the replay in slow
motion everything was in slow motion
except the football right i mean it was
you couldn't even still see the football
it was still like tracers on there it's
unreal oh matt casey said that not you
oh the hell with him he's a jets fan we
don't want to hear what he has to say
uh
and here's the thing i i'm not ready to
rule out patrick holmes in the mvp chase
because chris i really do believe that
it's so tied to getting that one seed
and there's gonna be an afc one seed in
nfc one seed and i think the quarterback
from one of those top seeds is going to
be the mvp so if it's russell wilson and
patrick mahomes both with the one seed i
don't know how that's gonna pay out
but if it's not
if it's not wilson
right
and if it's let's say it's it's the
buccaneers of the one seed then you got
mahomes versus brady i mean i just think
the one seed is going to drive it and if
the chiefs are the one seed it's going
to be hard to not give it to patrick
mahomes 21 touchdown passes one
interception so far this year that one
came against the raiders that was the
jeff heath pick that's right and that's
that's that's a game that that the chief
should not have lost they should be
better than a two loss team but they're
going to keep rolling they're going to
get i think that game kind of woke them
up and they're focused now and we're
going to see them not stumble against
lesser teams and continue to play well
against great teams all right next one
for me
let's see what do i have here how about
the didn't you used to be taysom hill
award
because taysom hill they're finally
using the guy yeah he scored a touchdown
right he he had i i got to get the
numbers up here but it's the the most
he's done offensively all year i'd still
like to see more out of him i still
think he's capable of being a bigger
piece of the offense and i think the
saints are going to regret not using him
more if they don't uh start winning
these games a little more easily and
start losing some games like i think
next sunday night they need to go heavy
on taysom hill yeah but it's it's good
to see him finally playing the way he
did in that playoff game you know if you
were like oh you're you're too high on
taysom hell it's like did you not watch
the viking saints playoff game there's a
reason i'm high on taysom hill he was
the best player on the field that day he
had 35 rushing yards on five attempts
yesterday and he had 30 yards receiving
including a 20-yard touchdown so you
know he should be in position to have
more than 65 total yards in a game yeah
he didn't throw a pass which is good i
guess but uh he should be doing it all
they should be getting the most out of
this guy they paid him it was good to
see it yesterday they they you know they
let the bears hang around more than they
should have i stunned the bear scored 23
points but i i was happy to see more
taysom hill if you're going to pay this
guy the money you need to use yeah i
agreed and you know they're a team
that's you know a little offensively
challenged as far as explosive plays
you know to where that's where i think
he can really help them out a little bit
you know again it's just can you always
ask and can you always expect your
offense to go on 10 and 12 play drives
and nobody rip off a big chunk of yards
on a certain play camaro is really the
only guy that can do that so that's why
i mean i'm with you i think they need
more taste of mill i don't know what to
think of the saints i really don't you
know i just who
how good are they what what are they i
don't know
there's things about their team i look
at them and i just go man i like it
offensive line defensive line you know
of course brees and they can execute on
the the offensive side of the ball the
defense has moments of being dominant i
mean as far as yards are concerned it's
a top 10 defense in football but
i mean every week they let up big plays
and when you're letting up big plays to
nick foles and the bears that's when you
know you have a problem with letting up
big plays because they don't make big
plays against anybody they can't they
can't you could take the defense off the
field most weeks and they still can't
make a play so
that is concerning to me and i'll tell
you the other thing is concerning again
you know again drew brees outside you
know the numbers will look okay
yesterday i get it
but
man the ball
was
not looking real peppy yesterday and
that would concern me too because if
it's the playoffs and they got to go
green bay
you know seattle something like that
where it could just be a little nasty
you know it's just a huge disadvantage
for the saints football team that way
and they've got the game at tampa bay
next sunday now on nbc then they host
the 49ers uh so we're gonna learn
some more about the saints in the next
couple of weeks we'll see if they get
michael thomas back the ankle became a
hamstring
that they had the disciplinary issue
with him a few weeks ago they need him
back on the field they need him to be
focused and determined and and if he
comes back and you know we're talking
about all the the things that antonio
brown can do for the buccaneers
as of next week well if michael thomas
comes back he can do even more for the
saints so you know if they've gotten
through this stretch without him and
he's going to come back and be the guy
he was last year there's no guarantee it
feels so long ago that he was that guy
yeah you almost wonder can he be that
guy again but if he can be that guy
again there's no reason to think he
can't be then that that could be a
difference for the saints but look
they have an opportunity a huge
opportunity on sunday night because if
they complete the sweep of the
buccaneers because the saints won back
in week one then then that makes it a
lot harder for the buccaneers to jump
them for the division championship chris
yeah no it definitely does and you know
the way it looks right now i mean you
know we'll watch tonight but we fully
expect the buccaneers to win beat the
giants and
you know the the buccaneers just when we
talk about good football teams they have
a lot of the aspects of the things you
like i mean there's just really not any
glaring weakness or one thing that we
can just
there's nothing i mean it really isn't i
i really i mean what is it what do you
what is the weakness of the buccaneers
what do you think it is like just off
the top of your head i know i don't even
know either i'm truly just going off i
don't what i mean inexperience in the
secondary maybe i mean that's it's
really about as far as i can go i don't
know if there's anything else where i go
oh well brady's not throwing the ball
downfield no check he's throwing it
awesome they run the ball they pass
protect they could stop the run and that
was one of the questions early on the
offensive line was going to be good
enough especially if he was gonna hold
the ball let guys get open down the
field yeah the offensive line has gotten
better on the fly and i don't know what
he's doing i don't know if it's his
presence i don't know what it is but
that team everyone is elevated they have
the guys that were questionable coming
into the year are getting better and
that's just part of that championship
vibe that tom brady carries around with
him isn't it it it definitely is that's
what a great quarterback does we've
talked about it a lot this year you know
the great quarterback you know it one
gives everybody confidence in the locker
room like hey we can we can win every
game we can win every game that guy's in
the locker room and then
nobody wants to disappoint that guy
either so everybody raises their game
they don't want to be uh oh you're the
jerk that keeps messing up huh you're
the reason we lost nobody wants to be
that guy so he's awesome and then bruce
arians and byron leftwich deserve a lot
of credit because i believe they have
really
molded or got brady to be a little bit
more aggressive and they did it in a
smart way
they've really done a good job of being
like when you want to throw the ball
down the field right no risk it no
biscuit bruise aryans they have every
time he does that for the most part they
basically max protect it keep seven
eight guys in so he can go back with a
clear mind and not be peeking over his
shoulder or anything like that and i
think that's given him the confidence to
get back there and fire again and you
can see now he's starting to fire no
matter what what the protection is and
that's where they're scary and we'll see
how scary they are tonight um here's a
question for you yeah here's a question
for you before we go to your next super
right
because bruce ahrens was talking about
this last week that he hopes that that
they win it all and both todd bowles the
defensive coordinator and byron left
which the offensive coordinator will end
up getting jobs elsewhere yeah as head
coaches right what if they win it all
and aryans walks away right which of the
two guys ends up taking over that's what
i just thought of when you just said it
i just went wait well what if aryans
could walk away this year this could be
it for him
i i mean
i don't know i guess
if they're going to keep tom brady in
the thing they got going rolling i i i i
want to say byron leftwich i think a lot
of todd bowles too
he's a good defensive mind and of course
he was up here in that crap stew called
the new york jets and it's not easy to
be successful there
um
but leftwich i feel like is like that
young
gonna be that young hot offense of mine
mike to where i just don't know if
organizations are going to be willing to
part ways with that type of guy
yeah that's right because if you make it
balls you got leftwich one more year or
or if you don't give it to leftwitch you
may lose him right if you give it to
balls as the
be elsewhere as a head coach right away
right so uh i don't disagree with that
all right give me one more superb uh how
about yeehaw ride that horsey we got a
horsey in the race that's right yeah
indianapolis colts don't forget about
them they're
i thought i thought you were talking
about the patrick mahomes tyree kill
touchdown well you're right that was
some uh yi horsey too you're right no
doubt about it but
i mean sitting there top of the division
with the tennessee titans we haven't
even talked about the colts five and two
real good win by them yesterday i mean
really saw it all you know again philip
rivers was pretty good played a clean
football game you know they were able to
run the ball and their defense showed
some of their dominance once again you
know and really the defense put the game
away the game being what was it at that
point 28 to 14
then stafford throws the pick six but
really
i want to re re-talk that the defense
really it was 20 to 14
caused a fumble then made it 28-14 then
got this pick six to go up 35-14 so
really a well-rounded win and the even
the colts have been a little bit of a
roller coaster this year and they're a
work in progress a little like the tampa
bay team we just talked about there's
still some elements of their team that
are very intriguing and we probably
don't give them the credit we deserve
because they have been up and down but i
think they're going to have a say in
this afc before it's all said and done
too
but that's the thing with the colts once
we start buying i know they damn that
then they crack their bed as you would
say like they did against the browns and
so then we we pull back
and we're like all right we're going to
wait and see and then they start piling
up wins like all right we're starting to
believe so we're setting ourselves up
yeah right they've got the ravens this
week yeah i i i
already know there's your chances right
prove that you really do belong and
prove that those two losses that you
have are aberrations
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports